this is Lucan bradleby and he's a first
year student at Hogwarts when we begin
our journey in Hogwarts Legacy fans of
the game had been concerned when
previous footage seemed to only show
students of mostly the same age as our
main character which had left many
wondering whether or not we'd see
younger students roaming the halls in
Hogwarts Legacy this is just one of the
numerous reveals we got from the new
gameplay showcase which focused on the
Character Creator combat and Hogwarts
Castle itself now speaking of Mr
bradleby how great is that name by the
way he heads up the crossed wands
dueling club which was another new
reveal during the Showcase crossed wands
is a student-led club at Hogwarts for
practicing your dueling skills it's also
a club the professors at Hogwarts are
clearly aware of but let the students go
on believing they're actually keeping it
a secret the club was also highlighted
in a recent Twitter post from avalanche
now it's here at this dueling club we
got our most detailed look yet at the
combat in the game courtesy of game
director Alan too and we have quite a
few combat reveals to get through
starting with the fact that the R2
button fires off off what Avalanche is
referring to as a basic shot the spell
effect itself is red and it's unknown
whether or not this spell translates to
any specific incantation from the series
such as say flippindo or Stupify which
both do feature red spell effects rather
than mapping all magic to one button or
even the triggers Avalanche has instead
opted for a system which groups the
Spells based on two primary categories
essential and slottable the essential
spells can be activated on controllers
with the left d-pad button these are
spells needed in very specific contexts
and also spells the devs want available
on the controller at all times revelio
was mentioned as a specific example of
an essential spell during the gameplay
showcase at first I thought we would
need to bind and swap out different
spells on the left d-pad as needed but
after listening to Alan a few times here
I'm pretty sure he means that the left
d-pad spell will change based on the
context of where we are in the game and
what we're doing at a given time so
while it may be revelio in one instance
it will be something completely
different in another now as for the
slottable spells to help players better
understand their function Avalanche has
separated them into different
color-coded categories Allen
specifically mentioned damage force and
control spells during the Showcase but
we actually see four different color
codings damage is almost certain to be
the red and I'm thinking purple for
Force but things like accio and pulso
and then yellow for the control spells
such as lebioso which by the way is
notably different from Wingardium
Leviosa the latter allows the Caster to
move the object once it's levitating
whereas the former does not now the
color I didn't mention is the one on the
left which is a light blue and contains
the spell lumos now one other
interesting note about lumos here is
that it does not appear to have a
cooldown whereas all of the other
slottable spells seen during this
showcase do have a cooldown as they're
used the color within the icon is
depleted and then begins to refill now I
think it's pretty safe to assume there
are definitely going to be ways to
improve this through things like potions
and or upgrading the Spells when it
comes to the number of slottable spells
Allen confirmed there will be more than
20. we mostly saw these four here during
the Showcase lumos on the left levioso
on the top and accio at the bottom the
one on the right is still a mystery so
let me know in the comments which one
you think it could be defendo perhaps
throughout the rest of the Showcase
including the little Montage at the end
we got a brief Glimpse at some
additional spell icons like the purple
one here I think it's probably going to
be depulso and then two of the red ones
here which again are a bit of a mystery
we know red is probably damaged so the
left one here I could see being expulso
bombarda or maybe even reducto
considering the icon on the right has a
wand I'm thinking Expelliarmus for that
one the yellow one on top shows the open
palm of a hand making a stop gesture and
if we were right before about yellow
being a control spell this one should be
impedimenta which is used to slow down
or stop targets now before we get to one
of the best announcements I think of the
whole showcase we do have to discuss
some of the disappointing announcements
as well and the first one here is
confirmation that we won't be playing
mini games like Wizards chess or
gobstones in Hogwarts Legacy just like
quidditch though both are going to be
part of the world just not playable for
us we've already seen the chess board in
the common rooms and in the gameplay
showcase we talked to an NPC by the name
of Zenobia NOK who talks about playing
gobstones now when it comes to other
activities around the castle we already
know about the dueling club which we
mentioned before as well as the flying
challenges brewing potions and all of
the vivariums so it remains to be seen
what other activities will be in the
game to kind of help fill that gap
between the main story another
unfortunate bit is that house points
will not be a core mechanic in the game
they dropped this news as we got a look
at the house point counters which are
gorgeous by the way and again like
quidditch gobstones and wizards chess
it's certainly not like they're going
outright to just ignore house points but
my guess is that it ends up being more
story driven than our character earning
house points say every time we learn a
new spell answer a question correctly in
class Etc okay for number 10 here and
what I think is one of the best reveals
of the whole showcase we finally got
confirmation that our choices at least
some of them will matter ever since
Avalanche updated the official FAQ to
say the game will not have a morality
system our choice is not mattering had
been a bit of a concern from fans myself
included thankfully Alan confirmed this
is not the case and that our choices
will matter if the students are a way to
kind of like flesh out the school
opportunities around it what what we can
do and then those interactions uh
different interactions with different
characters can also offer different
Choice points for the player and then
some of those things can can affect
things game wide some of these affect
characters lives the ending of the game
um and sometimes it's just about you
being a little bit here just being a
jerk so the scale really varies but but
uh but those opportunities exist for the
player the other huge news drop from
Alan happened when the player character
stepped outside of Hogwarts to take a
look at the surrounding area and when
you see things like you you'll notice a
bridge over there that's a place you can
go to cross like everything is
everything that you see is a place that
you can visit wow did you guys hear that
I actually had to go back and listen to
make sure that I heard what he said
everything you see you can visit and
this is one of those things that
continues to amaze me about Hogwarts
Legacy I mean the castle alone is going
to give us so much to see and explore
and do but then when you throw in the
surrounding area and don't forget about
hogsmead it's just so exciting to think
about all we're going to be able to do
not only in the castle but outside as
well when it comes to the castle one of
the biggest questions we still had is
how will classes work and Alan answered
this one as well he confirmed that they
opted against a totally simulation type
experience so you don't have to worry
about missing class or having to plan
out your day around classes in Hogwarts
Legacy he said that while yes there are
day night cycles everything is based
around the narrative and they see it as
being similar to different chapters
within that narrative Allen also
mentioned that each chapter has its own
set of missions that you can choose
between as you play the game and that
classes fit within that struck picture
the gameplay showcase also gave us our
first look at one of the dorm rooms in
this case the Hufflepuff dorm Chandler
made sure to point out the Exquisite
design of the bedside tables I also
notice how we see what appears to be
something similar to a chocolate Frog as
well as a pack of birdie-bought every
flavor beans now what's interesting
about this is that birdie bought every
flavor beans hadn't been invented yet
birdiebot himself was not even alive yet
in 1890 when the game takes place so I
think that's probably going to be
something else when it comes to
Chocolate frogs though things are a
little bit more up in the air now I'm
pretty sure I've mentioned before on
this channel that chocolate frog cards
wouldn't have been around yet I've heard
a number of people say this so as I was
writing this video I thought where the
heck do we get that information so I
started doing some digging tonight and
when it comes to the invention of
chocolate frog cards the only thing that
I could find is that there was a daily
profit article that appeared during the
Fantastic Beasts films and you can see
that article right here I guess you
could say the front page now the
specific headline you want to look for
is in the bottom left corner here notice
this doesn't say anything about being
invented it only mentions a new
packaging now because of the light blue
color on this one I don't think we can
say for certain 100 it is a chocolate
frog now it could also be an earlier
version of peppermint toads which do
have that light blue in their current
packaging which is featured on the
official Harry Potter Shop website now
if you remember back at the state of
play gameplay reveal we definitely 100
saw a pack of chocolate frogs on the
right side of the screen during this
scene here in the room of requirement so
could we actually have a situation here
where the people at Avalanche have
caught this particular error with the
packaging before most of us in the
fandom and have actually already
corrected it here in this most updated
look at the game alright now that we're
out of that rabbit hole let's move on
from chocolate frogs because it does
appear we'll be able to bring a pet with
us to Hogwarts because we see two
different owls here in the Hufflepuff
dorm room in one shot we see this owl
and then in another we see this owl no
confirmation yet on cats or toads or
even the function of these owls will be
able to interact with them at all we
don't know that yet it is also worth
pointing out though the vivariums
mentioned in the state of play Gameplay
trailer where it seemed as if we'll be
able to have a variety of different
creatures there and we could help nurse
them back to health after rescuing them
from poachers now there were a few story
details mentioned as well the first and
I think the biggest reveal here is that
the field guide is actually being given
to us by the ministry of magic now a lot
of us had guessed that this was going to
be given to us by a Hogwarts Professor
now perhaps fig or Professor Weasley is
going to have something to do with that
but Avalanche confirmed here in the
gameplay showcase that it does in fact
come to us from the ministry of magic
and it is a special book for us to help
us get acquainted with Hogwarts and I
think this all ties back to the
beginning of the game and what our
character survives what is it that makes
us not start Hogwarts until our fifth
year that is the big story component
that we still don't know now it also
seems like we inched a little bit closer
to confirming the Hogwarts Legacy
Headmaster there was a moment of
dialogue here where this character
mentioned the former headmistress
eupraxia mole rumor is that a former
headmistress Professor mole conjured
them to protect the contents of certain
locked cabinets years ago Professor
black couldn't be bothered to disenchant
the Keys and they appear every few years
so I think once again this is pointing
in the direction of Phineas black being
the Headmaster while we are at Hogwarts
and the other big reveal with this
gameplay showcase was all about the
Character Creator we finally got a look
at the last tab and through that last
tab we got confirmation that we will be
able to name our character both first
and last name now this one I think is
pretty significant because a lot of us
had been speculating do we descend from
a famous Wizarding family is the last
name going to be set I think a lot of
people thought this was a possibility
because then characters in the game
could actually refer to us by our last
name I mean how many times have you
heard throughout the series people
referring to Harry as Potter but this
screen here confirming we will set both
the first and last name now in terms of
names I was also struck by the fact that
all of the characters all the students
we interacted with throughout the castle
all have unique names we already
mentioned Luke and bradleby and zenobi
and Oak but even in the dueling scenes
you can see the characters that we are
dueling here in fact have names as well
now it is slightly different when we get
outside of Hogwarts we can see in the
very last Montage right at the end of
the Showcase there are some Wizards
we're battling here and they're
referring to them as ashwinder Scouts so
they didn't have actual names but I
think it's pretty cool that all the
students we meet and interact with we're
going to be able to see their actual
names so when it comes to research start
doing your research now to see if any of
these characters are possibly related to
characters that we know in Harry
Potter's day Allen was also asked a
question about what can be changed about
creating our character once we've
started part of the game so can we go
back and change things and the answer
here is yes and no you can change things
like haircut hairstyle hair color as
well as your accessories like the
glasses but you cannot change things
like your skin color or your eyes face
type all of those things which again
makes sense so the things that are
purely cosmetic you will be able to
change those the other stuff once you
start the game you're locked in there
are also some things that were missing
from the Character Creator no body types
such as tall and short or heavy and
light builds and then it also doesn't
seem like we're going to be able to
switch to our left hand there had been
some speculation that maybe we will have
a left-handed option after seeing the
character on the official art book for
the game but personally I feel like if
that was going to be in the game it
would be here somewhere in the Character
Creator now there are so many more
details about the Character Creator and
I just had to make a completely separate
video breaking that all down so if
you're curious about that I'm going to
link that here on the right side of your
screen now check that one out next and
as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon